hi my name is Hallett and in this video
we'll take a basic Gatsby example and
turn it into a Content full-power
website let's get started
here we have the Gatsby documentation
website and it's telling us to install
first Gatsby CLI
so let's do that
you
once that's done it's setting us to
create a new site which is using Gatsby
and then new gets beside so we hit enter
it's installing all the packages now
you
okay the solution is done let's CD to
the directory and start gatsby develop
or it's all there's always this MPM
script so we can do NPM around ever
now it's building all the stuff
and once it's done it will give us the
link to our websites if you go here this
is a very basic SP web site and with
navigation now let's install the catsby
source control plugin to be able to pull
the data from contentful so we close our
server when we do npm install and then
we need to save the gatsby source
content for plugin hit enter
you
once that's done we need to add our
content and credential into the Gatsby
coffee
so we go to our get speed come to Jess
and as you can see here it only has one
plugin so we need to expand this and
then in here our plugin will be defined
as an object because it accepts some
configuration option so first would be
resolved and then here we need to type
the name of the plug-in which is gatsby
source content one and in here we need
to pass in options and basically the
options are two things one is the space
ID which we will get in a minute
and then we have the access token which
is the deliberate access token that you
need to do in there so let get let's get
these credentials
so I go to app but content for the
cuckoo and then in here I select my
space
I already have two predefined articles
of the trade well I need to go to the
API stab and then in here I just add
in UK and then call it gas p website but
here I'm not gonna do this because I
already defined Mikey
so I go here first I get my spy CD and
now need to get my top and we should be
set
okay so now we need to write some Gatsby
a specific code to be able to create a
page for each blog post to tell Gatsby
that we need to create some pages
dynamically we need to export a function
called create pages so we do exports
create pages and here we get an object
as a configuration we are interested in
the graph QL function and then the bound
action creators
so this will be a function in here first
thing we need to get the create page
function from the bound action traders
this really used to map a path to an
actual react component and also we will
need to return a promise since this is a
promise based API you can also use the
callback but that's you can check that
in the documentation so here our new
promise will have the resolve and reject
as usual
now we need to get the path to our blog
post template that we will define later
so for now we'll assume that it will be
inside the assessee and templates folder
so we call it blog post template and
then here we'll use the path of resolve
and then SRC templates blog post Jess
and here of course we need to define the
path
[Music]
it's basically mainly important
okay so here we need to call the result
function and instead of our load
function will have the graphical
function that will accept our query and
our query basically will be all content
follow block and then here the limit be
100 can make it up to 1000 and inside of
these all block content will will have
edges and inside of edges will have note
and in there we'll have access to all
our fields that defined in content for
like slug ID and so on we're only
interested in the ID and slack in here
the rest of the data we can pull it on
later so you might be wondering why this
is called all contentful block where
this name is coming from so if you go to
your website to the content of that
excuse me and then go to your content
module you can see here is there's a
blood content type
and there's also author Content ID what
the Gatsby source content plugin is
doing is actually getting all your
entries and they grouped them
it grouped them based on the common type
so here basically we are asking the
Gatsby to give us all the entries that
are based on this content type which is
blog so think of it as all content fold
and then here is your content type
you're gonna type ID basically ok so
here we change this back to blog so in
here the scrap function returns a
promise so we need to resolve that and
then it will give us a result and the
result will contain an error if
something wrong is with the query so we
should check for the errors result dot
earth here we just simply reject and we
passing the earth so we can see them in
the console otherwise we can just create
the pages based on the data so inside of
result there will be a data object and
inside of the data object you will need
to follow this through so here will be
all content full block or all content
whole whatever the content type you
looking for and then in there it would
be there will be edges and edges
basically are like all the objects that
contains our data so we need to look
through them so we need to do for each
and then here we get for each edge
we need to create a page so here we call
our create page that we got from the
bondage grade and the create page will
accept an object sorry so first we need
to specify the path for that and the
path for that will be edge dot node and
then slug so the slug is the unique
string that defines the path for our
blog posts
and also we need to map that to a
component in here we just need to
provide the path of the component to
Gatsby which is here the blog post
don't late yeah wait a spelling mistake
in there
yeah not valid and also you can passing
some data to the component through the
context and this is actually will be
useful later when you want to use
queries a graphical queries inside of
that template component so here we are
interested in the slab so we pass in
just a slag because we'll use it inside
of that object to get the data related
to this blog post so it will be edge
don't know dot slack just need to return
here and we hit save
we need to create our blog post template
so we go to SRC and then we add a new
folder called templates and side of it
we create the file called the blog post
yes
and then if we go here this is our
template component and then here I need
to define my component and here we will
call it blog post component we don't
need these styles
and we don't need the Khan sector you
don't need all of that and that's clear
these completing step okay so this is a
key component
first we need to add the prop type to
our component so here types equal to
we'll get a data we will see where this
is coming from later and this will be a
type dot object what is required
and also here we need to have a query
specific to this template and to tell
you guys about it we need to export a
variable called page query this will be
the template string with a tag graph QL
and then here we do query load post cool
so this is basically just as defining
this function name it could be anything
so this will accept a slag of type
string and once we get the slag which
we've been passing it through the
context and the Gaspee nodejs we call
content well block so content will block
this is the sink so alternative block is
the collection and this is just
just getting one entry based on this one
based on some filtering we'll be doing
and we will pass the slack and it should
equal
to the slack our slag
and in here what will be getting is
titled and slack for now so after we get
this data we need to fill in the render
function here so we can for now just
have some deer and side of the tail we
display simply for now the title so
maybe we can wrap this in an h1 and then
we hit save
you
and for the title we will be getting it
wrong the props so title is actually
coming from this dot props but theta dot
content role blob
and then it's a
so if everything is fine now we should
be able to run this and test our website
just building and it failed you probably
were screaming at me because you forgot
this new promise in the beginning when
we were creating the Gatsby no Jess so I
added that and our website should build
why not now we do NPM run develop
you
and everything's fine yeah now the
website it looks the same but we
actually created pages and the test this
we can trigger the 404 page of cat speed
basically by just go to the paw report
or adding any random ID and the good
thing in developed mode when you trigger
the 404 by her get speed will show you
this page and will tell you all the page
that was created and as you can see here
we've actually created our pages so
people here this is one of the blog
posts title and here again even if you
go back to content one then you check
our content these are the titles so for
example like do you know hacks and it's
here and we can check also the slag
which is matches this slide
so so that's great but we need to list
have a list of all the articles on the
index page which is very easy we just
need to change the index J s so if we go
to our source pages this index J s
[Music]
let's remove all of this that we don't
need and then do if I say you can see
that reflecting here because now we
don't have anything and then we need to
define another component in here as a
function we call it a blog post you'll
see why for a moment in a moment and
then the blog post we get prompt
sensitive crops that would be an odd
object and then here we simply return
the jsf that we need and to be just an
item inside of a list so and i and then
here we just do blink this is a special
special link object coming from gatsby
so it knows which when you knows how to
map links to a component so it's route
so we tell it to go to node for slack
and then here for the text it will be
node or title
and then we close the link here
and then for our index page we get data
inside of the props and then inside of
the tip instead of the tip so we'll have
a ul and then in here what we're gonna
do is we do data but all content whole
blog dot edge is so similar what we did
in the Gatsby note yes and then we map
all that data to a component which is
basically the blog post component and
then we passing the node so to be edge
dot node and then we need just to close
this yeah that's it one more thing we
need to have a query for this page to
fill in the data so again we export the
page query which would be a template
string tag record and then here again
same thing query H query
and the page query will be all content
whole blog because here we actually want
the collection and not a single entity
and then here we do a filter filter will
be an object and inside the filter we
need to have the node look al I'll
explain a bit why we need that and then
here the locate will be English us so
why this node locating thing is that
tentacle the Zeus plugin for content
falling gasp its uses the sink endpoint
and all the data is coming in the form
of locale and then you get the field and
here by default my website has only one
lokay which i think is us but you can
make this super dynamic and maybe get
the German one and and so on but for
default there's always the English us or
the default locale space if you go to
space settings and locates you can see
this is the default okay it might be
different for you but mainly but for me
I use English us so that's why I put in
here English us okay what we want to get
from there we have hedges is always
inside of the edges there's the node and
we need to get the title of the blog
post and the slug so we hit save and go
back to our website
and you can see here we have the list of
all the blog posts
and here I go back you have everything
let's improve our website a little bit
more so as you can see here we only show
the title so worried about the content
so the master keys to debug any sort of
data in Gatsby is to use the local draft
your server is spawned with any
development built as you can see here
it's showing us the link
so if you go there you can see that we
can create our data and also there's
autocomplete so if we go back to the
search for our blog posts you can see
that there is a field called content and
yeah by the way I added a featured image
because we cannot be using it later to
show off some of the baked in feature of
content for images so it would be using
the image API so going back to the
content this is like the content of our
blog and we basically wanna show it
so let's check how we can query that so
we can first bug that and once we have
the correct query we can move it to our
blog and then show the content based on
that so the field is called content so
here we can add in just content and
content if we hover over it is actually
a text note and the text note is handled
as an object and gets me when I want the
schema is created so we actually need to
get the content of that content and then
when you hit play you can see that all
the content is displayed in here but
there's one problem this is actually the
role markdown data which is not that
useful for us so you want basically HTML
to work with to do that there's a neat
package called gatsby transform a
transferable remark so this will detect
any text node that has Bartlow and then
parse it for you and would add a lot of
neat features so let's test this first
we need to install it I wanna cancel the
bed and do NPM install and then I need
to save it and then the name of the
plug-in
[Music]
you
so that's the install we need to go to
our let's pick on pick
in here and then if we follow along it's
a matter of just adding this plugin so
just I'm just gonna copy this and then
after content below we can
add our plug it in here and then don't
forget comma then we hit save
so let's see what's changed on our
content after we have this blog
so maybe we can also clear the cache and
the public folders and then do NPM run
develop as before
this will go through with wheeled all
the data query the data for content and
so on and here if we refresh
let's check what we have inside of the
content now so if you go here based on
the plugin we will have an HTML in here
so
we can actually to this child my tongue
remark and inside of that we can get
HTML and there's also the elixir so
except is just a short few sentences
from the whole content we can show it
basically in the list of blogs but what
we're interested in is actually the
parse HTML of the markdown content
and if you see here there's the first
content so let's add this to our
detailed component so the the one that
will show our blog so if we go to the
template
and then go all the way down here so we
follow along as we have in the graphical
and I hope I pronounced it right so it's
gonna be content inside of content we
need to get child Mart down remark and
inside of that we will have the HTML
so we say everything is compiling but we
are not gonna see that until we actually
have the data in so we can create it
even here
and then from here we actually can get
content and then in here we display that
which is content and here you need to
follow down the whole sections of
content and self content is child
Martin remark and HTML so he's saved
hopefully things will work no
let's see do it
oh yeah course
it's safe and hopefully here
you're building and then if you got it
boom we have our chemin here but it's
actually not parsed because react will
consider this as a string and not an
HTML so what we need to do is to tell
react to treat the content as actual
HTML so we're going to delete all of
this and then there's a function called
dangerously
you
dangerous Liva can spell it right it
said in our HTML and this will accept an
object and inside of that we will have
with HTML and this HTML would be our
content thought child okay yeah
so it's child might on remark dot HTML
so if everything is fine
this should warm fully yeah it's
compiling and as you can see here we
have you need structure and everything
is parsed and you can see and the second
dollar blog post here's the other one
and another one
all right that's big world so let's also
add a little bit of text in here to show
like a teasing or an excerpt about what
we are expecting inside on the detail of
the article so we might get like the
first 100 200 characters so to do that
let's go back again to our graph cursor
and play around to the data so instead
of HTML we can do except so we can do
excerpt here and you can see it's some
text from the content we can actually
say I want the first 300 characters from
there and you can see it this is changed
but for now we can just use the
the default behavior which is here so
that's that so we need to go to our
index page which is the page that lists
all the blog post in here
and we need to add content and inside of
the content we need to call the child
markdown remark and we get x ur
if we savor things
here we can just add another tip inside
of here
we can do note not content child right
down
we won't sir
and then we close the div tag
and hopefully when we save
in shop
did
so
content
Charlie one town yes course I made a
typo and we save and as you can see here
we are able actually to display next and
I'm sure with some CSS you can start
this the way you like and that when you
go here we receive the full blog post
so one more thing here is we maybe want
to show for example the featured image
so I've been I had already and did the
same image pretty much do all the blog
post
which is here
and to test this again we can go to the
same server and then see so if we call
it a field it's called featured image
so after
content here as you can see it's
available in the autocomplete and then
in here what the content will plug in
the Gatsby plugin will add is some neat
features which is some extensions to
actually give you a responsive image
size so we can actually do response
resolution and then inside of the
responsible Russian we can give an
argument
so I want it to be like 300 maybe and
then we can actually do hate and then I
want it like 300 and this will
automatically create for spending New
Orleans to be using the content for
image API
so from here we can get this or she we
assess she said and also you can get the
aspect ratio and the base64 and so on
so here we are for now we're just
interested in the assessee and then if
we do this you can see here that it's
calling getting to the image or content
hole and passing the parameters in here
you can check these and the
documentation I will link below so you
can actually do some transformation and
the first hit to the content endpoint
will be processed and then other any
same hit with the same URL it will give
you like a cached image so if you
request a three point 300 by 300 image
and it doesn't exist could have will
create it for you and cash it so the
next time you just get the cache cached
version so no extra processing
so let's add the image to our list so I
want maybe an image in here and then the
text
again we can update our query so we go
here and then we want the featured image
and I want sponsor resolution
and I want with
300 and hate 300
and I'm interested in the assessee
so here we can just add our image tag
and then we have the assessee we are
getting the SSE from note tall
future
feature image
and then
and see the structure here so
responsible resolution
and solution we have SRC
so hopefully this work and we can see
here the image obviously it's not
well sty but you can see here it's
there's the image there's the link to
the blog post and so on so if you click
here you can see blog post you will try
to connect everything together and make
our blog build automatically through sir
PCI whenever you publish an entry from
potential or you do a normal commit but
before doing that I would like to add
some CSS to my blog to look nicer so I'm
gonna add already and added some CSS if
you go to the layout and then see index
CSS then go all the way to the bottom
and this is why I added it's just basic
CSS so to see the result we need to go
here to our UL list of blog posts
and and do class name and then call this
blog post and then once we save
and by the way it's server still
learning that's why I had Auto refresh
okay
so now we have this kind of grid hanging
but this is a blog post I added but if
the publish date supposedly if you put
content well it should be
October 18th 2013 so it should actually
be in the bottom of the list we can
solve that using sorting so so we need
to go to our index page that lists all
the blog posts and then we add the sort
sorting in there we can do easily this
real quick here so this is the filters
we have here and then you can just add
another parameter which called sword and
the sword accepts the fields so you can
actually sort based on multiple fields
but for now we just saw basic on the
publish date and then we have the order
should be descending just like that and
then we save and then go back to our
server and we need to print again
because the query needs to build again
and then over refresh
everything should be fine and then
they're like as you can see here the old
blog post is actually on the bottom of
the list
all right so this is looking good
we can now start configuring our Sir
Percy I so this is what's the first
thing to do is to create a folder called
circle so we can just do a folder called
a circle CI and inside of that we will
have a config Yammer file and then we go
here
and then here
first thing is we eat answer Persei that
we want to use the new shiny version -
and here we tell it about our jobs so
the jobs one will be building so this
event we want to build to only run when
we are in master so any experiment you
want to do in a separate browser you
don't want like the Surfside to deploy
to your website or maybe you wanted to
go do something somewhere else so and
then all the new builds and sub CI are
based on docker images so we configure
our image so say image and then circle
CI and then node 7.1 or 7.10 and once we
configure the topper we tell the build
process how to do the steps so first
step would be check out this is a pretty
financier PCI and we want to do some
caching so we don't need to actually
rebuild everything we will do everything
from scratch every time so it will store
cash and here we need to pass in cookies
first one is the key based on the
package.json so we just wanna the
checksum of our packages
and we need to pass in a fallback key in
case there isn't any already cashed
items which is actually very useful
because the first time we commit this
and nothing will be fouled there so we
give it this the NSE is and once we're
done here we run out force command so we
do run and then meeting is we can
actually name every step we do here so
you can do program will install
dependencies and the command in there
obviously it's NPM install or your
whatever you you're using and we need to
save our cache
this is tutele Sirte CI to save the cash
so that is here we can do note others so
it s absurd to save the nose modules and
then
give it the key
actually here this needs to be two
spaces back
so the key will be v1 and then C is and
then the checksum of package.json and
now we need to run tests so since we
don't have any tests in here we can just
do a simple echo like no tests so
echo has the exit exit process with a
number zero so it will be considered as
successful and now we need to build our
cat's pubes it so we need to define
another run step and this will be named
build and then the command that we need
to run is npm run build which is
specified in our package Jason after
building
I would like to install the AWS CLI
since I would be deploying to s3 so I'll
be using the database reality so the
step will be named installed AWS CLI and
the command is since this is multi lines
we can just do pipe and then do sudo
apt-get install Python yep
and the reason we are installing Python
is because the AWS CLI is dependable and
Python and the latest version is always
in the Python paper so and then here we
need to install our stop you see I and
after we have that here and we obviously
forget about them and then here
I need to deploy to production so the
name is deployed to s3 and our command
would be AWS s3 and then we need to sink
in there
and then we take the folder public and
then it's s3 and then the path of our
back bucket so I have a subdomain called
preview my website and so I'll be
deploying there and then I want to
delete anything that I actually deleted
before
and of course I need some cash control
it is really nice for our set aside so
in Madrid and so on and we don't want
the process to load them every time you
load the website so we will catch them
and after that this is an optional step
but since I have cloud froth on top of
my s3 bucket I need to invalidate all
the caches in the in the CDN in there so
before doing that I need to enable cloud
front feature in AWS CLI so we can do
this through this command is called AWS
configure and then set preview dot
create annotation true so that's the
command that we need to use and it's
called create and validation and this
will trigger what's called invalidation
in cloud want to delete all its copy
through all the servers and then get the
first one and then now it's time to
start the invalidation so here we can do
create or start cloud round invalidation
and then the command will be AWS cloud
front and then you get the idea
create and validation and then we need
actually to pass our configuration as
JSON is the easiest way I found
and then I'll be copy-pasting the
station because I actually can't
remember all of it here and then
boom this is all the nutrition I can
actually explain it a little bit so for
placing the ability creating the
invalidating and invalidation sorry we
need the cloud front instance so every
cloud front instance has like this kind
of an ID so you get it from AWS and then
here you tell it to clear the path like
the main path and star so this means
like delete any reference or any cash
for every file in there and from there
we actually are done and the Emma file
so we can just save this and then I have
somewhere it's in texture duplicate my
pinkie we all that's fine
because I need that yeah but maybe it's
this is my J slender
somehow is picking this stuff up yeah
now we can what we need to do is define
this cloud front instance as a command
line bar in circle CI and one thing
actually here after like if your project
is public after this emulation is
created actually the CLI will spit out a
JSON that contains the instance of your
cloud front and this is okay because you
still need also other credentials to
create a validation but if you want to
hide all of these logs you can just
simply redirect
the errors and the STD or an STD out to
the deaf man so this way you will run
the command but any output will be just
ignored so no aquata for this which is a
nice trick to do
circus if I provide actually a nice tool
to verify or config yeah Mel before even
push it to ripple so we can actually to
circusy i config by the date and let me
keep it the file and true tell us that
okay or config file is valid so that's
nice
for now we need to go to circle CI and
then we add our project and our project
is actually in here and it's called
contentful against be content philosophy
which is this guy in here
simoom ego and person
and then
we go to our site and click setup
and then here this is the project so we
need to push everything in here and when
we call this let's see I person to add
everything and committed
and then I hit
you
okay all is good we go here and don't
start building
it should pick our configuration so
let's give it a few seconds
you can see it's going through the steps
that we defined so purses is soluble
installing of dependencies
you
this will take some time as it's the
first time doing this
so I'll speed up the recording a little
bit under which the next step
they no tail because it's actually
expecting some command-line wires that I
need to add in there and if we go to our
pets become pig
you can see it's expecting if these two
environment tires so let's do that
so we need to go to settings and then
environment variables and then meeting
we do a hat this is the space so we go
here this is our space and then we paste
in in here and then we add another
variable which called
token and then we put our space api's
and then get the token from here
and then we add to bar
and
if we go back
and then hit rebuilt
you
and that's done now it will use the a de
Blasio to deport s3 bucket
and of
fails because I need to add the s3
credentials in here so first let me go
to console
but Adam Leah stop
so I go to the am
in here I go to my users and then I go
to this user
and got the security credentials
and I get my excess key
you
and then they go in here and there's
actually
AWS permissions I put in my access key
and then this I save that
and we go back to our build and then
rebuild again
so I just realized that we don't need
any cloud font and validation here
because how it it set up the s3 bucket
is it has no cloud front answers on top
so it's just pointing to an s3 bucket
after this if I go to my preview website
you can see that I have my website here
ready and it's deployed next part is
actually to go to first we need to
disable this cloud front and validation
so let's go to the code and to our
config and then we just delete the
oldest part
and then we add everything allow me to
commit
and we can push that
okay let's take a look on how we can
automate deployment whenever we publish
an article on content role so we can do
that through the web hooks we can go to
space settings web hooks and then we add
a new workbook here we can call it
gatsby website and then the URL is this
one which is a URL to the server CI API
so here we need to specify the username
and then in here this is the project
name which is basically this one
and we need to tell it which branch to
build so usually this is master and then
here there's token so we need to get an
API token from circa CI so we go here is
a settings and then personal API key is
and I create a new one and I call it
let's be content whole website and then
add it and then copy it and now just add
this token in here and I only want this
weblog to be triggered whenever I
publish an entry on publish an entry or
delete it and same for assets and of
course if you have a preview environment
you can for example do it and what to
say so I hit save then I go back so if I
go to my content go to this title and I
want to remove this extra word in here
and then hit publish
so this should trigger
circusy I built so it's in here and as
you can see it started
and it's running and it should deploy
the new website here's building
you
and deployment is successful so if we go
in here
we still have our website deployed and
now we have the full circuit so whenever
an editor goes in here and then add the
blog post so let's just add a test blog
post so we call it this is a test and
then we have test content we can link an
image and the date should be today and
author
it's here and then I hit just publish
so this should trigger another build as
you can see it's what it's running so
now hopefully when I go here I can see
then you open in here
so this is a test which is the same so
we can also go here and delete it and
this is of course we start again another
build and we will end up with a website
without this book blog post